what's going on this guy here
um sarang actually asked the question he
said
hey why are we working out this n rather
than working out 10 10's the question
right as you can see in part a right the
reason why i went to
end what we call the general case is
because you can use it for
every other question you ever need to
get asked like part b
okay i've started from this aven and
then i've said well the money runs out
when it gets to zero do you agree with
that
right at some point like i don't know n
equals 20 or 30 or 40. at some point it
will hit zero and then
you've got no money to withdraw okay so
what i'm doing is i'm taking this whole
a of m that's everything in that red box
there
and i'm letting it equal zero and now
i'm trying to solve okay
now the way you can know your head in
the right direction is see how the
only unknown is m so when i solve this
i'll get n equals something which is
what i'm trying to find out
when this all takes place now i'll admit
it looks really terrible and
intimidating okay but you have to stay
with it and i'll show you how to do that
okay
from this line to this line i have not
done very much okay this is
this is the line as shown over there
what's the only difference between here
and here
the denominator yeah thank you just the
denominator i was like 1.04 minus one i
can do that okay
the next thing i notice is and um when
you get to it on your line if you're not
already up to it
i want you to notice right n is what i'm
after okay
but it's it's tangled up it's the index
right so i'm like i have to deal with
this 1.04
to the power of n as well i've got it
there and i've also got it here
so these two guys are kind of like my my
they're my like terms they're my
x then i'm trying to get them to
simplify together but right now there's
all this complicated arithmetic in the
way
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
try and get that arithmetic out of the
way
for starters i notice i'll do it in
orange
i notice that all of this stuff
it's just numbers do you agree with that
and i can put that into my calculator
this times this divided by that okay
so if you haven't already maybe you've
already gotten past this line of working
in yours but i haven't
go ahead can you work out what 75 000
times 1.04
divided by 0.04 can someone tell me what
it is
zero i actually think it will be a very
large number
oh hold on i'm getting a couple i'm
getting a couple different numbers here
so i i've got my calculator here as well
we're doing 75 000
times 1.04 divided by 0.04
what did we get i've got i've got an
answer here now
yeah one one nine five and then four
zero
okay thank you that's matches what i've
got so just be careful if you've got
something different
um it's super easy to just put a decimal
somewhere else okay
now this replaces all the stuff in my
orange box so now it's 1.04 to the n
minus one equals zero okay i'm keeping
my eye
on these guys here right they're the
things that i want to collect together
all right are you like oh uh i can just
expand this can't i
this guy here can just expand i've got 1
million lots of this thing
like so and then i'm going to minus this
that's how many other lots of it that i
have is that okay
i've done this part and then i've got
watch for the double negative
minus 109 1.95 million
times minus 130 plus uh 1.95 million
right
equals zero okay this still looks gross
there's still so much going on but it's
better isn't it wouldn't you agree this
is better than my top line
i've got no more fractions i've got so
um
i've got much fewer terms right i can
work with this right
by 1.04 the power of n there's a million
over here
and there's 1.95 million over here so
how many do i end up with
this yeah it's gonna be a negative right
it's gonna be negative
950 000 i think
1.04 to the power of n go ahead and
check it if you want
a million take away that right i'll also
get this guy but
that doesn't have anything to do with it
so i'm going to kick it over to the
other side is that okay
so i will subtract 1.95 million from
both sides which gives me this
like so and now i'm on the home stretch
look this this n is within graphs i i'm
just going to divide through
like so by minus 950 000
so the negatives are going to go
uh like so is that okay
i'm dividing by this right not only do
my negatives go but a whole lot of my
zeros are going to go
is that okay yeah yeah 39 over 19.
30 yeah you can put that into your
calculator again yeah you just just
just stopped it over your head right 39
over
19. and we've seen this before
we've seen it before where the unknown
is in the index what do we got to turn
this into
a log very good i need oh i've got space
already okay so i'm going to take
log yeah the base becomes
the base over there becomes the base
1.04
right and then everything else
rearranges okay so i'm going to get 39
on 19
inside of this log 39 on 19.
that should be m right you're going to
need your log laws to deal with this
because your calculator doesn't have
base 1.04 it's only got base e and base
10.
it doesn't matter which one you use your
log laws will tell you this
for change of base wait so why did you
put 1.00
yeah it's coming from here it's coming
from here the base
careful the base of your exponential
will become the base of your log
you